[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared here and today we're
talking about one of the more thoughtful
Marvel properties out there dared up and
no not the Ben Affleck one also spoiler
alert for all of you that haven't been
jabo seasons yet Matt Murdock blind
lawyer and human lie detector is a
vigilante the devil of Hell's Kitchen
the very concept of Justice is based in
the idea that law ought to be fair this
is why justice is personified as a blind
woman holding scales on the sword to
weigh guilt and execute said justice
it's no coincidence that Matt Murdock is
a blind lawyer that beats people up in
his pajamas the other element the show
plays a significant emphasis on is the
fact that matt is a Catholic the choice
to name a Catholic superhero Matthew
after the apostle and evangelist is
quite apt as a tax collector Matthew
would have a similar reputation to
lawyers today the book of Matthew does
quite a bit of commentary on greed in
social justice Matthew 25:31 through 46
sounds a whole lot like a justification
for pro bono legal work and Matthew 23
16 deals explicitly with corruption and
blindness in fact the promotional
material for the second season was
heavily influenced by religious art
including Caravaggio Michelangelo's the
Last Judgement and Rubens st. Sebastian
which echoes Claire's fears about Matt
you know the only thing I remember from
Sunday School is the martyrs Saints the
Savior's they all end up the same way
bloody alone whether it be divine law or
man-made law the central theme of
daredevil is justice so let's get to it
welcome to this wisecracking edition on
the philosophy of daredevil part 1
justice and responsibility
daredevil addresses a serious problem
with justice legal liability whether or
not a guilty party ought to be held
responsible for their actions sure it
seems simple enough somebody goes on a
killing spree
they deserve to be punished right but
that narrative is complicated by one of
the central questions in daredevil are
people responsible for their life
situations in season two Nelson and
Murdock attempt to use PTSD as a defense
for Frank Castle saying that Frank
doesn't know the difference between
right and wrong and thus he's not
responsible for his actions
Frank Castle is actually a good man he
just he doesn't know the difference
between right and wrong anymore
when little Frankie castle box at this
they reword their defense to sympathetic
storming mr. castle is suffering from
what we call sympathetic storming a
diagnosis where the sympathetic system
is on a heightened state of alert due to
extreme trauma and emotional disturbance
Frank castles been through hell again
the idea is Frank Castle is not
responsible for his actions the show
asks is a person still to blame for
their actions if they aren't free to
choose the person they've become Wilson
Fisk is conditioned into a world of
violence by his abusive father until he
well snaps Elektra is presented as an
emotionless killing machine that can do
nothing but murder because of her nature
as the black sky Elektra is literally
predisposed to be evil and a significant
portion of the second season revolves
around the question can she exercised
her free will to deny her destiny Frank
Castle has experienced the complete
horror of war lieutenant Frank Castle
that I know is a hero only to return
home and see his entire family violently
gunned down can one really blame him for
being vengeful and then there's Karen
we've already seen her murder one person
and the show constantly hints at her
mysterious dark past and did some
digging into your past activities do you
really think this is the first time I've
shot someone Karen has to believe that
someone like Frank Castle isn't all bad
that he isn't defined by his deeds
because if he is she is and always will
be a murderer that might not be
important to you but it is important to
me they don't think that you're a
monster but I know that you're not
you're not philosophically speaking the
idea that all decisions are determined
by previous causes is called determinism
determinists don't really believe in
free will all actions are just
consequences of previous actions each
choice a person makes is impacted by
previous life events in a deterministic
universe concepts like responsibility
and punishment don't really make sense
because if we're just a product of our
past that we don't really choose to do
the things we do and how can we be
punished for something we didn't choose
Matt represents a different view of
Criminal Justice
libertarianism which believes in the
ability to choose other than your
determined nature libertarians are of
the hopeful swords I mean Matt literally
wears rose-colored glasses Matt presents
an option whereby people can elevate
themselves beyond their determined
condition or environment
yeah I can't do that it's what Matt is
going on and on about on the roof with
the Punisher what about hope about the
redemptive spark inside of a person
where someone isn't all bad that they
can choose of their own free will to be
different
while Matt is supposed to be the example
to prove determinism wrong matt has the
devil inside him whatever that means be
careful of the Murdock boys they got the
devil and he wants to kill people like
fists but he chooses not to does he act
of his own free will or is Matt merely
unfree in his Catholicism it's not a
frank decision who lives revised that
self to God he's his choice not to kill
the kingpin a decision that he makes
freely or does he merely make this
decision based on the events that led
him to accepting Catholicism and all of
its precepts part to justice and
vigilantism here by day vigilante by
night vigilantism causes controversy
because the vigilante being outside the
legal system doesn't have authority to
distribute punishment there's no due
process or impartiality vigilantism is
common in comic books but in most cases
the hero isn't in a position to be
harmed by being outed as a vigilante
Elektra is silly rich Bruce Wayne and
Tony Stark are billionaire Playboy's
Superman can get shot in the eyeball and
be fine Matt Murdock on the other hand
is a blind defense lawyer who gets paid
in bananas and pies there is actual risk
for Matt if people find out who he is
it's part of why the daredevil is the
man without fear Matt's motivation for
risking so much is echoed by a Thurgood
Marshall speech from 1992 about
dissenting against fear was dissent from
the indifference you must dissent from
the apathy we must dissent from the fear
while justice Marshall may not be
calling for vigilante justice he is
calling for an end to fear and apathy to
not turn a blind eye to injustice though
vigilante violence is still extra legal
the question what makes a person good is
a central idea of the show and while
it's a little heavy-handed keep asking
myself if there's really a difference
between somebody who saves lives and
someone who prevents lives from needing
to be saved at all they make it clear
that Matt Murdock is just a bad day away
from becoming Wilson Fisk or Frank
Castle
one bad day away from being me most
superhero narratives play up the cliche
of good and evil there's a pure heroic
protagonist and a corrupt and vile
antagonist in daredevil however this
elementary distinction is blurred by
kingpin stick Elektra and the Punisher
who all occupy moral gray areas good and
evil
sometimes the delineation between the
two is a sharp line sometimes it's a
blur they don't set out to do evil they
validate their decisions by appeals to a
greater good for the kingpin it's the
glory of his City for the Punisher he's
merely doling out justice for stickin
Elektra there's a great war between the
chaste and the hand that they have to
deal with what separates Matt from Karen
the Punisher and the kingpin is faith
Matt is a Catholic whereas all the
others profess that they aren't
religious irreligious Karen my parents
were you can orphaned after the death of
his father he's raised by nuns attends
church regularly and makes an effort to
be a good man and see if we can find you
a better way to live in Hell's Kitchen
which is funny because Matt chooses to
dress up like the devil and kick the
[ __ ] out of people and so for Karen the
Punisher and the kingpin
there's nothing besides the corrupt law
to keep them from killing no divine law
that makes taking life unjust each
season Matt tackles different
adversaries but the actual enemy doesn't
really matter what matters is match
struggle with his inner devil with his
desire to bring justice to his city by
any means necessary
except killing Matt is a good Catholic
boy who likes hurting people but as a
real problem killing people something
about thou shalt not kill you couldn't
kill me a symphony that's what he had
other life except that he doesn't choose
not to kill
he kills Nauvoo three times but
conveniently forgets about it every time
he does so he lights him on fire he
throws him off a three-story balcony and
then he Chuck's him off a roof and at no
time does he express any guilt for doing
so so maybe he does have the devil in
him part 3 Criminal Justice a great
example of the dichotomy of Matt's
relationship to the law happens early in
season one when he exercises his ability
as a defense attorney to defend a
murderer he knows his guilty then turns
around and doles out some street justice
as soon as he leaves the courthouse or
how he fights the Punisher and then
defends him in court in season two
there's a constant refrain from
characters in the show
and that is Daredevils tactics as a
vigilante are half-measures
half-measures Manning I think you're a
half-measure
I think you're a man who can't finish
the job Fisk argues that what's
dangerous about Matt is not that he
wears a cape or a mask daredevil is
dangerous because he believes one man
can make a difference you think one man
a silly little cost make a difference
for Fisk it's only through sweeping
structural changes that come about
through influence power money eating the
same omelet every day that real change
can take shape city needs to die before
it can be reborn Fisk's argument is
echoed by both the Punisher and stick
that Daredevils vigilantism is
insufficient Matt clods through life
like his father a boxer who slides
through life taking on each opponent one
by one fight by fight for stick and
Punisher Daredevils insistence to not
kill limits his ability to effectuate
change how many men have you killed
protecting this city you're still afraid
to cross that line
Daredevils perps end up back on the
street to continue to rape kill and
murder
we both know in many ways the yellow
scene everywhere can be read as more
than just an omage to the primary colors
of the comic books it speaks to what
Daredevils frenemies imply that the
devil of Hell's Kitchen is really a
yellow-bellied coward you should have
just killed me coward in a
criminal-justice sense
daredevil justifies his actions through
a utilitarian approach his idea of
justice relies on rehabilitating
incapacitating and deterring the
criminal punishment is justified by a
forward-looking prediction to stop
future harm for the sake of all society
an action is just only if it advances
one of these goals like imprisoning the
kingpin and the Punisher sure there
isn't due process a jury or a judge but
this is a question of philosophical
justification daredevil does what's
needed in a predictive sense he protects
the neighborhood by beating the [ __ ] out
of people whereas the Punisher
represents a more retributive concept of
justice which closely aligns with a more
content approach to justice where's this
[ __ ] hand for Immanuel Kant it's not
a question of protecting society based
on the consequences of punishment
retributive justice is concerned with
people getting what they deserve
punishment isn't you
to help society so much as it is assure
that a person gets what they are due in
fact for the retributive s it would be
unjust or immoral to do otherwise you
want justice [ __ ] like us it's similar
to the concept of an eye for an eye or
lex talionis a system of justice which
requires the infliction upon a wrongdoer
of the same injury he has caused another
so yeah the Punisher punishes people
whether it's the kitchen Irish the dogs
of Hell or members of his ex-military
outfit Punisher acts to right the wrong
done to his family there's no legal
recourse he just does he ensures that
people get what they deserve
conclusion daredevil presents the story
of a conflicted hero torn between his
duty to the church the legal profession
and his desire to stand up for those
that are unable to stand up for
themselves
sure daredevil may be a Batman ripoff
but it did generate the source material
to create the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles well this is great
what makes daredevil a phenomenal series
is that at its heart it's a show about
kicking ass in a hallway in alleys
stairwells living rooms and cell blocks
it just kicks ass and he just plain
kicks ass hey wisecrack thanks for
watching this episode was made possible
in part with the support of my IQ so big
thanks to them for sponsoring the show
if you make a lot of driving trips for
your job or business you're gonna want
to check out this app my IQ works
automatically I don't think there's
really anything out there that makes
tracking categorizing and reporting your
mileage of this easy you just drive and
it logs your trips making it really easy
to then review your trips and categorize
them with just a swipe you can even set
up my like you to automatically send
monthly driving reports right to your
email with that you're ready to deduct
mileage for your taxes or submit an
expense report to your job I like you
makes it easy to just put more money in
your pocket and the other two big things
for me are that one even though it runs
in the background it doesn't hog your
battery battery use is actually super
minimal the other big thing is your data
is never sold or shared so be sure to
check it out for yourself it's
absolutely free to try just download the
iOS or Android my likeyou app and swipe
to categorize each drive the app takes
care of everything else and in support
of wisecrack edition my like you is
giving you all a special offer go to my
like ucomm slash wisecrack and you'll
get 20% off an annual subscription or
just sign up monthly to start tracking
I'm putting more money in your pocket
and we're working on more great stuff
for y'all so be sure to click here to go
to our channel page and subscribe you'll
be notified the second new videos are
released in the meantime I've got a
video on the Joker to work on so catch
you next time peace
[Music]